If you've ever spent days
chasing a bug in your code
or released an app to the
store only to find out
it has performance problems,
you will appreciate
the new debugging
and testing features
we've added in recent
versions of Android Studio.
Let's take a look.
Up first, joining
the memory monitor
that was available on
Android Studio for some time
is the new CPU monitor.
These tools give you an
overview of how running your app
is affecting the device so
you can spot performance
problems early.
If you need to get more
detailed information,
you can now start Tracking
Object allocations,
initiate a memory dump
for later analysis,
and even start tracing method
calls straight from the IDE.
There's also a new
performance captures
pane for quick access to any
reports that you've created.
They can be useful when you're
trying to find memory leaks
or identify performance
critical sections of your app.
But you know what's even better
for figuring out where a memory
leak comes from, knowing
which pieces of code
hold references to your
objects, preventing them
from being garbage collected.
You can see that
information instantly
during a life debugging session.
First, start your app
using the debug button
or attach to a writing process.
After a successful
connection, the IDE
will pause execution on any
break points that you specify.
Your can now select the Show
referring objects command
on any of the current variables
to get the info you need.
And speaking of
step-by-step debugging,
have you ever had to use it
with some third-party library
where the source code was
missing from your project?
Android Studio has you covered
with a brand new built-in Java
decompiler.
From now on, whenever
you need to check
the internals of a class
when all you have is
a JAR file is just one
click away in the editor.
And you can even
set break points
and do step-by-step debugging
inside compiled code.
How cool is that?
One of the other nifty features
that come with Android Studio
1.2 is the inlining of
values for local variables
right there in the Code
Editor when debugging.
So you don't have to look for
them in the variables pane.
Also, notice that when you mouse
over an operator expression,
you can now see the
resulting value in a pop-up
just like when you
mouse over variables
to inspect them in more detail.
But you know what the
worst thing about debugging
is, it's the debugging itself.
That's why you should be testing
your apps in the first place.
And with recent enhancements in
our Gradle plug-in and Android
Studio, there's now new ways to
write and run automated tests.
Whether you're doing
test-driven development
or just want to test
your code quickly,
one of the main pain
points was having
to deploy test to the device.
And we all know that takes time.
Starting from
Android Studio 1.1,
there is support for running
unit tests on your development
machine using the local JVM.
To use this feature,
first put your JUnit tests
in the test folder on
your Android module.
Gradle will create
a special version
of Android JAR in the class
path when you run the test task.
Be aware that this JAR doesn't
actually contain working code,
so you can't use any
framework classes.
You should use one of the
popular mocking libraries
like MOckito to mock the Android
dependencies that you need.
For tests that need
to run on the device
where the full
framework is required,
you can use the Android
test source set.
These tests will be
deployed alongside your app
and run on the target
device or emulator.
While not technically part
of Android Studio or Gradle,
we have recently
released a library
that contains many classes
that can help you with writing
and running your tests.
It's called the Android
Testing Support Library.
And it's available through the
Android Support Repository.
It gives you the most up-to-date
testing frameworks and APIs
made by Google, including an
Android Test Runner with JUnit
for support, the
Espresso library
for functional UI testing,
the UIAutomator, and more.
To find out how to set up
your project for running tests
using the Android
Testing Support Library,
follow these links and check out
our documentation and samples.
If you have any questions or
suggestions regarding debugging
apps using Android Studio,
you can join the discussion
in our Google+ community.
See ya.
[MUSIC PLAYING]